it will take a while to clear up but the
debris from last week's unrest is slowly
being removed even with a shoot to kill
policy still in place after nationwide
protests turned extremely violent in
kazakhstan's largest city
we passed boarded up shops where looters
had run riot but the traffic's in full
flow and the internet's back on a game
changer after six days absence from the
world wide web
we didn't leave the house only yesterday
and today
we are slowly getting back on our feet
ten thousand people have been detained
one of them a well-known musician from
neighboring kyrgyzstan was released on
monday at the request of kurdish
authorities clearly having been beaten
i heard from inmates that if you confess
that you were offered money and came to
almaty for the protests you will
immediately be deported to shike
it was a way home so i decided to
implicate myself
even though i didn't do it
it begs the question whether the
president's claim that this was a coup
pulled off by international terrorists
wasn't just a way to justify calling on
russia for help
this all happened extremely fast from
the way the protests spread like
wildfire across the whole country to the
sudden eruption of violence here in
almaty to the fact that president takaya
have managed to put a lid on things
essentially overnight by calling in the
assistance of russian peacekeeping
forces to help him restore law and order
now he says their main mission is
complete and that they'll start leaving
within the next couple of days
president takayev also blamed his
predecessor for a system where the rich
got richer at the people's expense music
to the ears of two homeless men that we
meet
there are no properly paid jobs but
there are jobs which pay pennies i have
10 10 gay in my pocket i want to eat and
i have no place to sleep
the sense of emergency is ebbing away
but there are deep-rooted problems still
to solve which foreign forces can't help
with
dinah magnay sky news almaty kazakhstan